is The Nightmare Before Christmas a
Halloween movie or a Christmas movie
sure viewers of all ages can indulge in
the stylish animated film for months on
end and still be in season but no matter
when you watch there are probably some
things you notice in the holiday classic
as an adult it's no secret that
Nightmare Before Christmas writer and
producer Tim Burton is a huge fan of
classic monster films early in his
career he directed the animated short
Vincent in which a young boy dreams of
becoming like his idol the beloved
classic horror master Vincent Price he
doesn't mind living with his sister dog
and cats though he'd rather share a home
with recent acts shortly after Burton
directed the short Frankenweenie which
would be expanded to a full-length
animated feature in 2012 in both
versions a boy named Victor Frankenstein
resurrects his beloved pet dog this love
of monsters of movies past comes through
loud and clear in Halloweentown where
The Nightmare Before Christmas takes
place the entire populace is monstrous
in appearance an adults will notice that
they're frequently references to
specific literary and film monsters dr.
Finklestein the mad scientist who
created Sally and helps Jack conjure up
a skeleton sled team very obviously
draws on Burton's love of dr. Victor
Frankenstein just about every monster in
town is a reference to a classic Igor
The Wolfman mr. Hyde the undersea gal
mummy boy the vampires you name a
classic and you'll find them living in
Halloweentown there aren't a whole lot
of kids movies about having a midlife
crisis but The Nightmare Before
Christmas is an exception Jack's been
the pumpkin king for far too long and
sees himself stuck in a rut he feels
bored with his life so he had Hazard Lee
throws himself into a new obsession he
assumes responsibilities that no one has
asked him to take on and makes a mess
that basically spans the entire world
for the most part kids aren't at risk of
reaching a point where they feel
completely stagnant in their lives the
theme of facing an existential void and
dealing with it in destructive ways
probably isn't too accessible to
kids though they can probably appreciate
that jack is seeking adventure in some
way for adults it's far easier to notice
the real-life emotions at the heart of
Jack's misguided actions throughout the
Nightmare Before Christmas viewers
witness a mostly one-sided romance in
which Sally in an endless effort to
prove herself to Jack is continually
subjected to his oblivious nature and
one-track mind
obviously children recognize a romance
budding here but it takes an experienced
heart to notice that Sally's giving way
more than she should for a guy who's so
wrapped up in his own existential
problems sally sweet nature and desire
to do good are admirable traits to have
but for most of the movie we're wasted
on a pretty selfish guy sally struggles
with feeling acceptance and joy in her
life in Halloweentown
in much the same way jack does but her
solution is to try to make connections
and help people instead of wandering off
and leaving her responsibilities behind
I can't help it it's a phase my dear
it'll pass because this is a children's
movie Jack and Sally get together in the
end and it appears as though Jack has
begun to understand how his actions have
consequences
we hope until he discovers Thanksgiving
town or something granted Sally's
obsession with someone she barely seems
to know leads to her creeping around
tombstones to get a look at him
poisoning her boss falling asleep
outside his house and throwing herself
out of windows but that's another
problem entirely one of the most adult
oriented gags in The Nightmare Before
Christmas is the character of the mayor
a squat two-faced humanoid who's
entirely uncertain of how to proceed
with just about anything in
Halloweentown without assurance from his
constituents most kids won't pay close
enough attention to politics to
understand what makes the idea of an
incompetent mayor quite so funny and a
little bit scary
the mayor's smiling public face
contrasts with the horror-stricken one
on the other side of his head
a conceit that tells the viewer he's
performing for the public when he really
has a host of fears about how the town
is run and his responsibility to keep it
running in an efficient manner
when the mayor approaches Jack's home
plans for the following year's Halloween
celebration and Jack does an answer
the mayor loses his cool I can't make
decisions by myself politics and hideous
monsters have never gone together so
well except in real life much like
politics most child viewers probably
don't have much first-hand experience
with casinos this is of course the V
boogies entire focus surrounding himself
with slot machines roulette wheels and
killer cards when Oggy rolls the dice
and announces snake eyes it's probably
safe to say that the kids watching only
really get value out of the snake that
actually emerges from the dice and not
what the raw means from a gambling
perspective nor would they gain much
insight when Oggy bangs on the table to
reset the dice to read 11 a much more
desirable role in this context but why a
miniature gambling world in the middle
of a place that's focused entirely on
monsters and Halloween mayhem what's the
connection the scenes and oogie-boogies
lair are some of the most fun but it's
interesting to notice that in this town
where the dreams of childhood Halloween
reign supreme the most feared monster
lives in a grown-up world with high
stakes that serve only himself when Jack
falls into Christmas town and leaves
overwhelmed by his excitement in this
new place he gets the wild idea that he
should try to make Christmas his own
without understanding the first thing
about this strange new land he attempts
to engage in research but without ever
asking any inhabitants of Christmas town
for their own input or advice he just
takes an entire holiday no questions
asked this year Christmas will be
of course this arrogance need to just
appropriate whatever he wants ends up in
disaster with Jack being shot at as he
attempts to spread Christmas cheer
throughout the land it's only then after
he's almost blown apart that he finally
realizes he's in way over his head and
he actually decides to ask Santa who he
kidnapped earlier
what the heck Christmas is even about
Santa the person who's actually immersed
in the traditions of Christmas town
decides to share those traditions with
Jack it's a much more genuine
interaction than Jack's attempts to
straight-up steal the holiday and it
introduces the good practice of seeking
out the advice of those with first-hand
knowledge on a subject rather than
blundering your way through something
blindly kids might not see that message
outright but adults will notice and
hopefully the nuance sticks with younger
viewers as they grow older check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]